les amis je crois que nous sommes au ski
mais
mon ami c'est l'heure de la première
piste je suis actuellement en train de
chaussée mais cette porte que j'ai eu à
noël je suis très heureux mais restant à
donner ça drôle
je sais qu'au fond de vous vous rêviez
de voir tomber eh ben c'est raté - rd
tha
malheureusement tout chaud
ok année on va maintenant faire le
boardercross d'un petit parcours avec
pas mal de virages de petites bosses est
assez étroite et si ça tout de suite
c'est parti
non
ok on peut dire que jamie a gagné sur ce
coup là voilà tu vois de la neige quand
il parlait c'est archi passion tu sais
il va l'argent bonjour on est en plein
tire fesses vous et moi les spas
romantique
par contre en bail un mec qui est tombée
dès qu'on est à l'arrêt attendez ça
remarche
[Musique]
yola hockey les amis nous sommes
maintenant snowparks et trois postes qui
s'enchaînent on va voir si je m'en sors
moi
photo
où est le sol natal
nous voulons film effondré de charros
novembre et pour cela on a fait appel à
un drôle de la voir
lp la meuf on va voir si elle va gérer
vasisht ya la toiture moment on est sur
le long terme et c'est pas ou qu'on
croit tous en elle et c'est la chute
c'est pas mal c'est le début oui oui oui
non et on va partir sur une descente
attention ça va extrêmement vite
oui oui oui
sa vache r là ok oui et non oui oh oui
oui oui oui et c'est la chute
elle a du mal à c'est très beau ce qui
se passera mais c'est sûr mais c'est
dommage qu'on puisse pas pas la traire
le drone chirac a laissé la chance à la
chance ça l'est un chance comme client à
l'an dernier bien que ces dernières
danses mais ce mardi les amis à youtube
heures ça fait quoi
ça travaille tu veux ta vie nature
montrent les sites tournera le sujet nul
lola la [ __ ] je vais au plat tiens
qu'est ce tu vas faire non non non non
non tauriel on vous désabonner à la
chaîne de squeeze voilà ça des galets
voilà tu veux avec précision chaque
étape qui le constituent c'est hyper
important à faire du bobsleigh dans
[ __ ] alors je tiens à dire que ça
c'est pas de nouveaux styles c'est juste
des t-shirts qu'un long terme et ce que
j'ai parlé à mes chaussures je serai
snowboard
grâce à vous grâce à l'âge aux abonnés
josé thermoformé c'est à dire qu'en gros
il aimait dans une machine qui la
chauffe énormément
non mais d eux d'apprendre des choses
aux gens et à faire des rideaux sur les
sites pornographiques
aude et donc c'est du tissu qui
maintient dans la chaleur c'est un
t-shirt thermoformé ces chaussures sont
avons formé le tshirt thermorégulateur
valable parce que je suis obligé de dire
le mot parce qu'il reconnaît pas ce soit
on va faire du bob c'est là que c'est
une luge qui va extrêmement vite ya une
piste pour limpide du move c'est ici à
la plagne tu es un voilà ça va être
intense c'est parti on y va
les années si on venait de voir c'est la
piste de bobsleigh est fait un kilomètre
de long elle est totalement immense et
on s'apprête à partir un maximum de
steam le style est présente en élite
bouillard de rigueur du car on est dans
la boue c'est allé très vite
moi je vais extrêmes ont peur oui à
temps pour ranger la can a induit on est
paré ouais on va mourir c'est sûr en
amoureux mais on aura des bonnes vidéos
oh [ __ ] c'est bien c'est que j'ai mis
une gaufre au mail sert à rien au moins
c'est parti
épargnée
m
hahaha
on est totalement en état de choc
les grandes villes violence rare c'est
un truc tout cet enfant de 6 ans vient
de le faire
on n'est plus un mal que oui du coup si
on faisait la question savent à 200
kilomètres/heure s'en tire en force à la
70e mais c'est ressenti ressenti guichet
c'est vraiment scandaleux
la vitesse à laquelle les gens passent
c'est juste fou c'était fou pensée omis
de notre périple est actuellement va les
faire de la motoneige ont brûlé des
galets la motoneige et du vin parce
qu'on est complètement mais on veut
toujours gêné mais du coup voilà
hexagonal pour deux jours un peu d'ogm
en bleu mais je pense que la moto mec ça
nous réveiller direct en plus voilà moi
je tâte un peu là la moto sur bitume
dans paris saleh rien à voir mais voilà
moi je fais un peu de quêtes on va pas
se mentir contre un an maintenant je
suis james est extrêmement froid assez
vous fall simone devant et derrière
qu'est ce qu'on a fait au même public
c'est un modèle très récent un modèle
très stylée pour vraiment pour les gens
pour beaucoup d'émotion à faire depuis
que 10000 est très sympa il a accepté de
monter à l'arrière de ma moto pour
pouvoir nous filmer pendant toute leur
remettre m an là dessus juste hâte loup
fuite des gants et un tour de coupe ce
qu'ils lâchent en train de mourir à gaza
mais c'est parti on y va je vais donner
du goût avec sécurité et nous à des
instructions geste doit pas se gamelle
ou quoi que ce soit j'avais bien faire
la fraîcheur et amis % présentent et vu
qu'on va aller vite et capa deux aspects
d'un casque de vérité
c'est pas mal j'aime beaucoup
désolé pour la qualité d'image est plus
très très sombres il a expliqué que des
foires va passer sur des pistes de ski
ok il ya des gens aujourd'hui il va
falloir se pencher du côté opposé à la
porte
et si l'amour plie mais va vraiment
tombé du coup j'ai trop la pression
ouah ça va c'est vraiment comme du cou
raide en fait c'est était que tout le
monde fait ses marques et un mac d'écart
avec le mc de bateau comme ça tu veux
faire une petite accélération
sympathique c'est parti
[Musique]
la vie des gens et en accédant ils ont
fait des tonneaux est ce que tu veux je
retire un peu la nhk la bouffe est ce
que vous pouvez faire ça exploration du
plastique
le paravent quoi il est parti à la base
je crois objectif atteint mais je
réussis à gaza ville s'assure que
maintenant je peux dire que les meufs
que j'ai été là en mission flash lite
elles sont retombées au certes on a
avancé plusieurs mois ah oui je la
trouvais fait du bruit et les deux bâles
haut du corps alors il s'était passé
quoi elle s'est perdue tarifs et c'est
une dure soirée pour ce moniteur de
motos ski ok ok c'est la fois ma
motoneige mais pas du style nul
en fait j'ai commencé à arrêter là on a
tout vu et c'était juste là on a vu que
la ligne d'arrivée et a dit m de quoi
remonter sur la moto neige on a une
déception colossal on est maintenant on
sort alors des cris jimmy on s'en bat
les couilles tient la main ils tiennent
en arrière des jimmy briand fait là je
vois ton bâton latuquois ok j'ai pris la
cam de luca on part sur de la tyrolienne
ce soir de l'accrobranche de nuit moi
c'est un max de frais on va pas se
mentir on va essayer de grimper aux
arbres sans se vautrer on vous retrouve
tout de suite
ok les amis on n'est jamais certain
c'est super merci du bien d'arriver à
l'accrobranche
on nous met des petits armée très sexy
et puis à parcours qu'elle a fait nuit
s'est illuminé les verts chaque plate
forme je voulais quelque chose avec la
gopro je veux exploser je veux terminer
ça dure une heure et demie orval
clochard là on a accroché une bo propos
de jimmy et c'est sous cette vie là que
vous verrez pas tous parcours parce que
si je mets la cellule vous ne paierez
pas on verra juste que je fais est
encore bien parce que je fais qu'on peut
la tour la filière
on commence d'entrée de jeu avec une
petite tyrolienne êtes vous prêt à voir
jamie s'envolait à jimmy kébé compagnons
d'armes quoi puis jamie charlot matadi
cela doit monter une échelle partie du
mur on descend une échelle
ok ok je descendais l'échelle assez
aisément à moi
c'est à des projets démarrés probook
j'en arrivai j'étais trop léger mdr chez
dupuis avec ma force en vendée mais je
trouvais beau monde à dieu dit tu vas
cadre et comme un trop haut mais c'est
incroyable ils cadrent avec son dos en
coop home et c'est fou mais c'est prouvé
jimmy tu es incroyable qui péjorent qui
tombe ça va tu les couilles à pour de
vrai là on était sur une boule et cet
homme descend il m'a sauvé le baudrier
tu es bon allez on va